okay you know and it invented a new
product and it's gonna travel
door-to-door selling like Avon virus or
something else not even close you say
anymore are you seeing anyone please
don't be disgusting I thought you were
seeing that girl with the exotic named
Bethany dad died when I was eight years
old you haven't been on one date since
then this is you worrying about me you
don't have to because I'm fine
do you want to come on my trip with me
mom you want to drive cross-country with
me yeah
no it's you know if we won't be gone
long it's only eight days
I can't wait Andy I am so excited
alright the adventure begins promise me
you'll never pick up a hitchhiker
promise I will never pick up a
hitchhiker good they rape they're ready
for your presentation Oh fantastic good
luck sweetheart
thank you ma'am nice to meet you what
are you doing mom please get off the
freeway you know I think I'm gonna drive
from now on good idea do you have any
rooms ville home for you and your lady
lady Andy they have clip-on frog
earrings Oh
- don't wink at me my mother you can
sing
look there's a restaurant oh but that's
a tapas I love tapas that's not what it
says mom please don't sit near me when
you were a baby your penis started to
turn purple I almost threw up all over
the table tell me if your penis started
to turn purple like my penis could
literally grow an eyeball and I wouldn't
tell you hi
you can eat our 50-ounce take that under
an hour you get it for free you know how
I can eat that your mom I was not
worried about that this week really
didn't go how I plan
I always wanted to see the Grand Canyon
I know how long are we supposed to look
at it 10 minutes seems disrespectful to
look at it formulas let's hole no that's
what a point it was the last time I was
ever there daughter
what a nice chapter mm is a beautiful
writer it's okay I picked up a
hitchhiker
hi oh I'll give you my number and you
give us a call when you're in town yeah
you guys should probably keep in touch